when
philadelphia's veterans stadium was
demolished in 2004
a secret it held for decades also went
up in smoke
until now i was ubiquitous i made it a
point of hiding in plain sight
tom garvey says he called the stadium
home for three years
he details his time there in his new
book the secret apartment
it was a great place to be for a guy it
was a man cave
it had everything the phillies and the
eagles played
60 feet from my front door i was like
willy wonka with a golden ticket
through a family connection garvey
landed a job managing the stadium's
parking lots
he used a storage room to temporarily
hold some furniture given to him by a
player on the eagles
but the idea to turn the room into an
apartment took root
when the vet's parking lot was about to
fill up
ahead of a visit by pope john paul ii in
1979.
i put together a skeletal crew from a
bar on south street friends of mine
and i couldn't trust these guys to show
up at four o'clock in the morning
uh with their clothes on and sober so i
uh
took them down there the night before
for a sleepout sleepover
and in the dark using that furniture and
sleeping in that room
somebody said you know if you just
cleaned up this place and rearranged
this it'd be a great apartment the
coolest apartment in the world and it
was and i'm
from that night on i stayed there garvey
a vietnam vet credits the solitude of
stadium life
for helping him cope with the trauma of
war
i had these times when the building was
just mine and nobody was
there nobody and i would roam around the
building or ride my bike upstairs
it was i was like 10 stories high
looking at philadelphia from a 360
degree loop
and i could just go round and round and
round and just lose myself
as with most legends there's no physical
proof of the secret apartment
only stories so we tracked down richard
osborne
he was that eagles player who gave
garvey the furniture that
kickstarted the idea it was a neat place
not that my furniture was all that good
richard everything he says
is true totally so totally he's not even
embellishing anything
they're going to be some people who are
going to be skeptical when they hear
your story what do you say to those
people
it's okay i wouldn't believe it either i
i started it all out with that i said
you know if i've heard this in a bar at
a party i wouldn't believe it
all right so no security cameras but
plenty of places i'm told for adult
beverages
i think he's going to start something
here at stadiums across the country good
stuff
all right well you can hear more of my
interview with tom garvey on today's cbs
this morning podcast available on your
favorite podcast platform a podcast
yes excellent i'll check that as a
character all right